hello everyone and yes don't worry
i will cover this game i've been
receiving a lot of messages uh for the
past few minutes as
you know it's not like this is one of
the games i'm not going to cover so this
is maybe
one of the cases where using hashtag
suggestion is not
all that important because of course
this is the candidates tournament we are
going to cover
uh not all of the games but all of the
more important games and this is a very
important one as
fab is trailing by a full point behind
the behind the leader yani
and geary trailing only a half a point
behind him so both of them
have an excellent chance of catching up
to the leader uh
in this in this game but uh that being
said i'm always more than
happy to receive your hashtag suggestion
so you know do do
share uh so uh let's check out the game
fabi has the white pieces
and he opens with e4 uh we have c5 by
gary going for the sicilian defense with
knight to f3 and now
e6 going for the so-called french
variation of d of the sicilian
uh we have d4 characters captures in the
now
knight to f6 attacking the four pawn
uh we have knight to c3 and now knight
to c6
putting pressure on white's d for knight
and now a3
so this has all been played before many
many times we have bishop to e7
preparing the castle and
bishop to e3 now you know we are now we
have now transposed into the timon of
variation of the sicilian
and here uh geary just castles we have
bishop to e2 by fabi and now
d6 and this position has been reached uh
quite a few times the castle season one
move here queen to d2 is a known move
here even uh the immediate the g
for reasonable move here because black
castled quite early
but here fabi goes for queen to d3 and
it is already as of move 9 that we have
a completely new game
and no doubt uh he created uh he
prepared something uh
special for this game as it's the
candidates tournament
he really needs the win to get closer to
the leader yanni pondichi
and it's a it's a tough position to be
in for both of them because
uh even though if this was just a casual
you know classical game both of them
would be happy with the draw i imagine
but since it's not uh of course both of
them need a win so here we have bishop
to d7 by geary
and now f4 uh kind of delaying castling
for the moment we have
e5 by geary striking in the center right
away saying okay if you're not castling
we're opening up the the position
uh knight captures on c6 b captur is now
uh improving his
uh presence in the center and only now
does fabi castle king side
uh we have e captures on f4 bishop
captures an f4
and now uh bishop to e6 now both the the
bishop and the queen need to guard
the d6 pawn so bishop to e6 and now
queen to g3 now kind of still having
pressure on d6 maybe the rook can come
to d1
improve the the tension uh and also if
you're not careful maybe ideas like
bishop to h6 will be possible in the
future who knows
uh so here gary shifts the knight over
to d7 he says
uh the d6 knight is actually defended by
a tactic uh point is if
you capture it bishop captures on d6
right away then queen to b6 check
and you go after the b2 pawn if king h1
we're just going to capture on d6 queen
captures and now queen captures on b2
the knight is under attack the the c2
pawn is under attack and it's not
it's not another great position for
white so instead after this knight to d7
uh there's no bishop to h6 right away
because bishop to f6 is just very strong
so it's pretty much pointless
so instead after knight to d7 we have
rook a to d1 like we said adding another
attacker here
and now rook to e8 by giri
for the moment uh queen to b6 check it
doesn't really do anything
but we will show it queen to b6 check
and now white can simply block with
bishop to e3
and now if you go after this pawn here
it's trouble for black because bishop to
d4
now uh putting pressure on g7 you're
threatening checkmate
and now of course if bishop to f6 you
can just eliminate it with the rook
and after knight captures just bishop
captures you with one material you're
still threatening checkmate
and it's uh you know a really really bad
position uh
to be in uh so what you would have to do
is after bishop to d4 play something
like knights the e5
block it this way but it's still
insufficient just rook to b1
queen captures on c to and now rook f to
c one and now
uh well after you move the queen to d2
which is the only square
bishop to e3 now traps the queen the
queen has no squares uh but
you don't lose the queen you can just
give up the bishop and that's it for
example now bishop captures and e2
bishop captures and each capture so
we're going to be up a piece
uh in a winning position uh so after
rook a to d1
queen to b6 still doesn't work so we
have rooked the e8 by giri and
now comes uh king the h1 and here the
situation on the clock is 40 minutes for
fabi 55 minutes for giri
and uh it's uh uh well more often than
not a nice prophylactic idea
whenever you have this diagonal opened
up uh when when
uh you know you constantly have to worry
about okay i play this what if queen to
b6 checked now okay i played this and
this would have queen to b6 check now
so this way you're playing to h1 and you
no longer have to worry about that
uh ever so here queen to b8 by geary
and now adding a defender to the d6 pawn
once again once again but basically now
going after the b2 pawn so here b4
fabi defends it and now knight to e5
blocking that attack
we have b5 putting pressure on c6 and
here
uh rook to c8 here we have traits uh
or rather captures on c6 with rook
captures on c6
and now knight to d5 and this is now a
beautiful square for the knight if black
wants to get rid of it he's to have to
give up the
light square bishop so instead we have
queen to f8 by giri
now uh preparing to bring this rook into
the game and now
c3 now the pawn is kind of weak here on
c2 so you have to defend it we have c3
uh and then now comes rook eight to c8
here
uh gear is putting pressure on that c3
pawn so rook to c1
and the fabi really spent a lot of time
here since he's the one with the white
pieces he's the one that's supposed to
be pushing
yeah but it's 16 minutes for fabi versus
40 minutes for giri
and he doesn't have all that much to
show for so here we have knight the g6
attacking the bishop
bishop back to d2 and now bishop to h4
the queen now has to move queenie we
have queen to e3
and now rook to c5 again threatening to
win material here but captures captures
and captures is coming
and now c4 the c3 pawn isn't all that
impressive here so here we have c4
yeah it's nicely defended here by the
bishop and by the rook and also maybe
you can use this
diagonal for the dark square bishop in
the future
and here gary goes for the absolute
strongest h6 now
he's preparing bishop the g5 which
immediately counters white's threat
white's threat was just bishop to b4
and now you don't really have the option
if you go for this now bishop to g5
and it's uh trouble for white so instead
after h6
we have queen to b3 by fabi and now
bishop the g5
and this is all very very impressive
stuff by giri
bishop captures h captures and now queen
back to g3
and now what do you play here the g5
pawn is under attack fabi has 10 minutes
on the clock gear it has some 21
minutes on the clock uh and here uh you
have basically two choices either
uh you uh defended the g5 pawn with
queen to d8 or maybe you trade first
captures captures and then maybe queen
to e7 defend defended like this
also attack the bishop here and if queen
f3 defending the bishop and putting
pressure on
black's f7 pawn then we can just shift
this knight to e5
and this is now officially a monster
knight because it's on a dark square
white has no pieces that can oppose it
and you can maybe trade it off for
for a rook at some point in the future
but other than that
you only have a light square bishop this
knight is staying here for the rest of
the game
uh it's attacking white's weak c4 pawn
also defending your weakness so you
really have nothing to worry about here
for the rest of the game uh but okay
gary went for a different idea he played
queen to d8 and now we have
rook seat d1 uh preparing to
to mount more pressure uh uh uh uh
uh you know towards this d6 pawn and now
bishop captures on d5 saying okay let's
now closed up
uh close down the d file and if rook
captures if you wanna
uh you know keep this pressure then we
can just play knight f4 and there's you
know
no counter play here for white uh it
doesn't really matter if you play rook
captures you can play rook captures
queen f3 uh defending the bishop but
that's pretty much it from white there's
not much
not much happening here so instead after
bishop captures on the e5 we have e
captures on d5 by fabi and now comes
knight to
f4 and as you can see this knight is now
much much stronger than this bishop we
have queen to f2
defending it and of course white would
be very happy if black would trade here
then the f7 pawn falls but
just rook eight to c7 adding a defender
here
even though black is never really
interested in giving up this knight it's
much better than this bishop
so rook to d4 adding another defender to
the c4 pawn also putting pressure on the
knight here
and now queen to e8 with a double attack
on the bishop
and now fabi's in trouble you can't
really defend it for example if rook to
e1 just rookie 7
we add another attacker here and if rook
to d2
and now just rook the e3 and that's it
white is basically without a move
uh if we try to kick away the knight
with something like g3 then you just
you know check mate the white king
queenie for checking g1 knight
h3 check king f1 queen h1 check and now
we're gonna deliver checkmate very
nicely
so after queen to e8 uh here fabi goes
bishop to f3
uh gives up the c for pawn uh but it
doesn't matter because he's going to win
the a7 pawn
uh however a rook captures on c4 was
played we have captures captures
and now queen captures on a7 but now
gear replaced
rook to a for attacking fabi's queen and
the pawn
and this is the critical moment in the
game where fabi has two options uh he's
on move 36 he has a few more minutes
before time control
and he needs to find the absolute
strongest move to survive this position
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the move that
saves the game for fabi while i give you
a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding
an incredibly uh difficult to spot move
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
no it's not that i'm only joking it is
of course uh queen to c7
uh it'd be weird if it was that since
it's white smooth i just wanted to make
a silly move and then i picked up the
black queen
what are you gonna do uh so yeah queen
to c7
and this is uh such a hard move the spot
point is uh you have to give up the a3
pawn
and then what happens is that uh you
just go h4
and that's how you uh completely you
know break harmony between black's
pieces
uh point is if the pawn is captured then
just queen captures and d6 now attacks
the knight and
the rook and this is how you uh just you
know survive everything and if
it doesn't matter if black doesn't
capture that pawn you have to play
something let's say you go knight back
to g6 now you play h captures and g5
and now you uh retain equal material and
you still
you know uh have pressure on these uh on
d6 and it's a
it's a very much playable position for
white however after this queen captures
an
a7 move uh rook to a4 now fabi played
queen back to
f2 and this simply uh is not enough
geary grabbed the pawn rook captures on
a3 now he's up upon
and he has a very very active position
we have h4 but now it's a little bit
different
uh giri just plays queen to e5 uh a
beautiful centralizing move with the
queen
also keeps an eye on the h2 square keeps
an eye on the a1 square so really
really does uh everything if needed uh
you know in the future those are
crazy arrows i know so here h captures
on g five by fabi and the situation on
the clock is two minutes for fabi 12
minutes for giri and two more moves
until we reach time control so queen
captures on g5
we have looked at e1 uh getting the rook
to the nice open e file maybe you can
you know put some pressure maybe some
bishop here to control
h7 maybe move it back maybe deliver
checkmate who knows
you have to try something and giving out
just goes back
rook to a8 and now comes bishop to e4
now a nice square for the bishop is
still uh controlling the now controlling
the h7 square
uh defending the pawn and asking black
what do you want to do here and here uh
bishop to e4 is one idea maybe you could
also play rook to f1 to kind of try and
put pressure on f7 maybe if the knight
moves you have a nice discovery but it's
all very very
uh you know and not the the greatest of
chances of that happening so
instead bishop to e4 like we said and
now comes
rook to a2 by giri and now this is move
40 both of them reach
time control and uh this is uh giri
spent quite a lot of time not a lot
maybe like seven minutes for this move
and uh it's funny because now that he
played fabi was awarded additional time
so
he has uh uh you know enough time to
calculate this move
but it's a it's a really nice idea
because if the rook is captured
then we just deliver check connect with
the rook and after the key moves we
capture the rook check king moose and
then we capture the bishop and then
we're of course completely winning
fabio of course uh not interested in
that fabi plays queen
rook to b1 and he offers the queen
because we already said the bishop
covers h7 so
if geary grabs the queen uh rook the b8
to check and there's only one move queen
to d8
rook captures on the a did this is now
checkmate the bishop covers h7
so instead after rook the b1 gary said
all right uh
i i i you did not fall for that he goes
back rook to a8
uh but the problem is giri's position is
so great uh that he
could afford this uh you know a little
uh inaccuracy
uh because instead of going this uh okay
the position repeated so i don't have to
show
it uh fabi went back rook to e1 and he
said okay if you didn't find it then
maybe you don't find it now
but now giri finds it as now he plays f5
and this is just uh
enough this makes all the difference in
the world because now you no longer have
back rank issues the bishop no longer
covers h7 you can play king to f7 you
can bring the rook to h8
and there is not much for fabi to do
here if i played bishop to b1
bishop to c2 doesn't really matter even
if bishop to ctu you can then play
something like rook here
also maybe harass white a little bit but
he played bishop back to b1
and now king the f7 it's a very safe
square for the king not
uh you know and nothing can can really
attack that king
and rook the h8 is coming so here rook
the e3
uh the rook no longer serves any purpose
on the back rank as this rook is coming
to h8
but this does not help fabi so rook to
h8 was played this comes with
king to g1 and now for the final time
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for geary while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding uh well
a lot of moves win just any move queen
g6 uh
g6 queen to h6 uh those are all winning
ideas that will you know win uh over the
course of time but
knight captures and gt wins on the spot
this is what gary played and it was in
this position on mu 45 that fabiano
corwana
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so really really a
tough blow for fabi he was really
trying to catch up to at tayani pomnichi
okay everyone is trying to catch up to
yan
uh but it is uh i i you know if someone
told me that in the second half of the
candidates room and fabi would lose a
game with the white pieces i would say
yeah that that's not happening
but here like it was a it was a a
position where
both of them had to win a draw it
doesn't really work for
either of them and then you know things
things just happen so here
fabi resigned because if you capture the
knight then just queen captures an e3
with
check and that's it there is no counter
play here queen f2 we're just gonna
deliver check
either pick up the bishop or if queen
blocks just to rook the h1 with
check uh we push the uh pull the king
away from the defense of the queen now
queen captures and that's just it we're
going to grab the bishop as well
and you know the game just ends in a few
more moves so after knight captures on
g2 fabi resigned
and giri is now uh well up a full point
from where he was that means
that since uh you may you know i'm not
going to spoil the results for anyone
but we still don't know how nepal's game
went
uh so giri definitely caught up to
nipple maybe he is
even ahead of him uh maybe you know uh
who knows maybe nepo is still in the
lead uh we're gonna
show at least one more game from round
11 and then we're gonna discuss the
standings as usual
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it really a tough a tough one
for fabi but
uh you know great great stuff for giri
he uh he's one step closer to
challenging magnus from the time
for the title uh i would like to thank
david kimura lucas berlund
robert lunier mohamed salisa and jacob
gonzalez for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament checking up on
your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day
and do keep those hashtag suggestions
coming